here at home if you are still looking
for work new requirements will likely
push you back into employment
this comes as hotels and casinos in our
area are working hard to fill positions
victoria saha has more on what some
locations have to offer
as las vegas starts coming back to life
and more guests are visiting
resorts and casinos need to keep up with
the demand las vegas is pretty open so
we're definitely experiencing an
increase in capacity with an increasing
capacity comes a need to fill up open
positions
at tuscany hotel and casino they're
hoping a job fair on april 29
will help fill their 30 positions we're
looking to fill
all levels of our departments like
really all openings are available
and it goes everything from hourly
to salary workers say the growth within
the company is what keeps them going
and helps attract new employees i've
been here three years
and i've been from front desk to bell
desk to gift shop
to administrative admin and now i'm food
and beverage admin it's a great place to
work
great place to start off if you don't
have experience we'll teach you
if you still aren't sure whether or not
you should go back into work
think again starting on may 1st you will
need to provide a proof of work
search to continue your unemployment
benefits so more nevadans start working
again
whether it's your pre-pandemic job or
getting trained for a new job